la peau des mines et qui est pas tous
les canadiens de la même façon pour les
albertains la crise économique préoccupe
autant que lakovic 19 l'économie
absolument parce que je veux que tu ma
famille et mes amis pour travailler et
ibf et ibo et en alberta 51e pour cent
des répondants identifier la pandémie
comme plus grande source d'inquiétude
alors que 49% indiqué que la crise
économique est plus préoccupante
la différence est frappante avec la
moyenne canadienne alors que 64 pour
cent de tous les répondants au pays ont
plutôt indiqué craindre la pandémie
contre 36% pour la crise économique
cette morosité se traduit aussi par une
plus grande proportion d'alberta 46 %
qui estiment que leurs finances
personnelles se sont détériorées
comparativement à 35 pour cent chez
l'ensemble des canadiens dans un même
ordre d'idée davantage de résidants de
l'alberta estime que le travail s'est
détériorée dans leur vie plus que les
autres canadiens
c'est une tendance qui se développe non
seulement depuis des mois et depuis le
début de la pandémie mais même à 20 la
pandémie pour ce politologue tous les
éléments étaient en place pour faire
dérailler l'économie chute du prix du
pétrole depuis 2015 annulation du
pipeline qui sonne excellent et de
l'important projet minier
à cela s'ajoutent des difficiles
budgétaire record l'alberta est plongé
dans un profond marasme
on est revenu en arrière enfin on est
revenu aux années 2010 à 2015 où les
gouvernements conservateurs ne
maîtrisait pas non plus les finances
publiques et on a l'impression que toute
l'économie albertaine fait du surplace
et le marché énergétique demeure et
prévisible alberton est posée revit au
bout de ses peines selon cet économiste
on se rencontre avec le changement
d'attitude au niveau mondial face au
changement climatique
à l'arrivée des investissements plus
durable que c'est une industrie qui va
demeurer à voir
inventera ça c'est important la crise
économique constitue aussi un sérieux
risque politique pour jason kenny alors
que le premier ministre était fait élire
en 2019 en premier temps de remettre
l'alberta au travail
déjà que sa cote de popularité avait
baissé à cause de la gestion de la
pandémie
le gouvernement conservateur pourrait
aussi être tenu responsable du surplace
économique ici mathieu gaye et radio
canada elle même